empty fuel pumps and queues of vehicles
that stretch for blocks the latest
chapter in Cuba's long economic crisis
there's no fuel we've spent three days
driving around we've been to six or
seven gas stations and the queues are
never ending
president Miguel Dias Canal says the
country is only receiving two-thirds of
the petrol it needs he's blamed Supply
Nations
the countries that have commitments to
us to supply us with gasoline based on
the agreements that we have with them
have also been in a complex energy
situation and have not been able to meet
those commitments
so drivers are organizing themselves
into lines and use and use WhatsApp
groups to find out where and when
tankers are arriving
some find ways to while away the time
if it doesn't arrive today it will
arrive tomorrow but I've got to be here
I go to my house I shower I eat I come
back with my guitar and continue
composing Cubans are used to spending
time in queues but there's something
almost surreal about this this line is
over 300 vehicles in it
and it's over a kilometer long
last week the government started
rationing how much petrol and Diesel
drivers can buy
this will allow us not to touch zero and
to cover vital services such as
ambulances necrological services and
transporting potatoes to the market
which requires diesel
one Economist says the main reason for
the shortfall is the cash crunch
without fuel for tractors harvests are
smaller if workers can't make it to the
factory productivity is lowered if
there's one sector that the rest of the
economy depends on its fuel
Labrada and his family have been waiting
around all day and have a long night
ahead my tank only has a space for 35
liters so I drive for two days and then
have to come back to sleep outside a new
petrol station in the short term it
means long nights and dreary days in the
long term it means more price increases
and an economy that produces even less
at Augustine Al Jazeera Havana